John Mayer welcome to caller Daddy thank
you Alex that's right John Mayer joined
Alex Cooper for an episode of her
podcast call her daddy and he opened up
about his feelings towards dating what
is your dating style like and how has it
evolved like what are you like I I don't
know I don't date that that much I look
at it like this dating is no longer a
codified activity for me it doesn't
exist John credited all to a lifestyle
change I quit drinking like six years
ago so I don't drink anymore I don't
have the liquid courage how do you feel
about that how has that changed your
dating life yeah to be honest
to express yourself you have to be
really
glaringly honest here's who I am here's
what I like here's what makes me nervous
here's what I reject as an idea in
relationship and the singer opens up
about the anxiety that comes with it for
him you have to express your anxieties
can't you can't just walk over them by
drinking you have to be like here's what
I'm anxious about and when someone in
life
accommodates your anxiety that's bonding
but when he first had a taste of Fame he
saw his dating life a little differently
I feel like I was made to believe
growing up that if somebody liked me
that was pretty much an accident and
that should be capitalized on and so
I felt very deeply when somebody liked
me
very deeply
and the 45 year old musician Finally
Revealed who his song your body as a
Wonderland is actually about it's
interesting to hear you say like it's so
crazy to me that six years after I
graduate college I'm winning a Grammy
for your body into Wonderland
you were dating someone at the time that
you're writing this iconic song which no
I wasn't you weren't no that was about
my first girlfriend the grammy-winning
singer shocked Alex revealing that the
song was not about then girlfriend
Jennifer Love Hewitt that was about the
feeling which I think was already sort
of nostalgic I was 21 when I wrote that
song and I was nostalgic for being
16. I thought it was about a different
no that's that's one of those things
where people just sort of form that idea
it gets reinforced over the years no no
no I had never met a celebrity when I
wrote that song